comment est ce que vous allez
aujourd'hui ce que tout va bien à ce que
ça se passe bien pour vous que serait ce
pas parce que ça se passe bien pour chez
vous le mec qui bug est ce que ça se
passe bien aujourd'hui on se parle de ça
on se parle de nouvel aspirateur robot
rock c'est le robot rock h7 vous ai
souvent parlé d'objets connectés pour la
maison parce que oui les objets
intelligents sont partout chez nous on
faisait beaucoup parlé de robot rock
avec les aspirateur intelligent qu'on
peut piloter avec son application saas
est un modèle un petit peu à part il est
moins intelligent que son grand frère
mais tout aussi pratique et je vous en
parle parce qu'il y ait trouvé sa place
très facilement dans votre intérieur en
complément de votre gros aspirateur
robot rock donc avec les deux vous avez
un combo parfait mais aujourd'hui on se
sent que là dessus on se concentre sur
le hcdh de robot rock parce que le h7 de
rue brock
il est super intéressant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et le h7 il est planqué l'avantagé tout
déballé je vous ai tous mais ici en
petits morceaux pour vous montrer lors
la première chose c'est le coeur en fête
de votre aspirateur et le moteur à
l'intérieur vous avez votre bac à
poussière qui est là le filtre à
l'intérieur il vient surchargées comme
ça la plus juste la montre est très
simple la toute première chose à savoir
avec ce produit c'est qu'il est hyper
facile à prendre
lorsque vous venez aspirer pendant un
bon moment et bien vous avez la
possibilité de venir bloquer
l'aspiration comme ça à agir tout seul
comme ça pour laisser bosser alors quand
même être là il faut quand même venir le
maniema est ce que ça vous évite de
venir appuyer sur la gâchette ici bon
voilà ça c'est un petit gain et c'est
très très pratique on peut venir mettre
une petite brosse est pour venir
nettoyer aspirer bon c'est cette
pratique
[Musique]
on vient mettre cette grande partie là
qui vient en renfort avec le grand cube
en mode gros aspirot pour la maison je
pense à grenade dans sa spears à tourner
en même temps pour venir admirer des
tapis pour faire faire des sols sa
trompe ces pratiques là vous venez
nettoyer les tapis les moquettes ou sous
voulait et on peut aussi en tout cas
pratique c'est qu'il vient reconnaître
que vous êtes sur un tapis donc il vient
mettre plus d'inspiration et plus de
puissance
couleur même carrément ça pour venir
chercher des choses au plafond voyez
comme ça j'ai inspiré un petit peu loin
atteinte des meubles en hauteur par
exemple si aussi l'arrière on va voir
également cette petite partie d'ac vous
allez ça et là ça tourne ça pour
nettoyer les matelas les couvertures les
coussins et enlever les acariens c'est
vachement bien regarder
[Musique]
pour respirer en précision vient
chercher dans les petits recoins où vous
auriez du mal je passe dedans
et là je viens aspirer tout ce qui est
dedans
et nouveauté cette année vous avez des
petits sacs vous pouvez venir utilisé
pour toutes les personnes qui sont
notamment allergiques
ça vous évite de venir respirer de la
poussière donc bon ça c'est en option et
c'est pas mal donc vous voyez
franchement pour venir mais tous les ans
debout que vous voulez c'est hypra hypra
hypra facile poignée ergonomique très
bonne prise en main facile à utiliser
donc ça c'est super et surtout ici là
j'ai un petit bouton qui va me servir de
switch intelligent sur mon écran
alors j'ai un petit écran oled il vient
changer au niveau des aspirations soient
très doux soit moyens soient très rapide
si c'est en mode très doux jusqu'à
leonard aspiration au moins
d'intermédiaires 35 minutes et 6e dans
le tournoi j'ai un peu plus de dix
minutes d'aspiration il m'a gâchette
avait juste là j'appuie et sas pire il
est livré avec cette petite base pour
venir le poser le fixe et vous le succès
contre un mur et vous emmène mis les
petites vies salek donc ça c'est très
pratique et surtout il ya une nouveauté
cette année qui vachement bien c'est que
ça c'est aimanté vous prenez vous posez
vos accessoires dessus et on n'a plus
besoin de s'embêter voyez à venir
trouver le bon endroit pour le poser
comme ça vous vous prenez vous enlevez
vous posez ça c'est hyper hyper malin
c'est tout bête hein d'y avoir pensé le
fait de rajouter ce côté magnétique il
ya la fin quand vous avez fini vous avez
une petite poignée ici vous n'appuyez
dessus ça louvre et s'avoue complètement
toutes vos ordures directement ici et
ensuite vous venez tout nettoyer vous
enlevez votre bloc là que vous venez
complètement nettoyé sous l'eau comme ça
pas de mauvaise surprise le filtre qu'il
ya c'est toi y est aussi très très
facilement sous l'eau est également
cette partie là qu'ils ont fait avec la
poussière
donc en termes d'entretien c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment vraiment il
fera simple la seule chose qu'on n'est
pas nettoyée si c'est l'odeur sont quoi
vous avez cassé donc ça c'est vraiment
la première option où vous allez
inspirer son sac
donc tout va venir ici vous tirer là ça
descend ya pas de sac c'est pratique
mais il ya une autre option vous pouvez
avoir un sac
la deuxième option ça se passe avec ça
ça vous venez de mettre juste là mais
juste avant vous voulez mettre un sac à
l'intérieur ça c'est la grosse nouveauté
cette année on l'avait pas que le hachis
sont là avec le h tête vous prenez votre
sac
vous venez le mettre à l'intérieur et
vous faites remonter tout en haut de
manière à ce que les cochonneries arrive
directement dans le sac et ne peuvent
pas remonter directement au niveau du
moteur prenez votre aspirateur
je mets dessus je tourne il est bon j'ai
plus ensuite qu'à mettre cette partie là
je remets dedans j'appuie s'est aligné
et là j'ai inspiré fut donc deux
possibilités
la première se fait sans sac et lorsque
je viens ouvrir et bien j'ai un peu de
poussière qui sort et si vous êtes
allergique c'est pas forcément la
meilleure idée donc la deuxième c'est de
utilisez votre sac ici alors la
différence qu'il faut revenir acheter
des sacs les jeter forcément pour éviter
les problèmes
donc vous venez commander vos sacs
l'étape j'ai mis tous les liens en bas
dans la description les jeter un petit
oeil ce qui fait qu'en jeu que vous
venez d'ouvrir et bien vous n'avez qu'à
venir tirer ici vous enlevez cette
partie là et vous venez retirer votre
sac de la même manière vous l'avez mis
et en plus à l'achat ya deux sacs de
fond dit il ya donc celui-là je vous ai
mis là puis on a un petit deuxième qui
est jusqu'ici
voilà une fois de plus ça vous intéresse
le lien est en bas dans la description
je sais pas si vous avez des enfants à
la maison
moi c'est mon cas j'ai un petit garçon
et si je veux pas qu'ils viennent
s'amuser avec vous laisse à appuyer sur
le bouton pendant quelques secondes et
vous allez voir que sans votre
afficheurs et bien ça a bien verrouillé
leur vous maintenez voulait s'appuyer
il a par contre rien à faire il peut
appuyer sur tous les boutons se passe
plus rien et pour venir le débloquer
vous n'avez qu'à laisser appuyer là
pendant quelques secondes de la même
manière voyez vous laisser vous laisser
vous ces petites parties avancé et hop
une fois que c'est fait et bien pauvre à
utiliser très facilement à noter qu'ici
on a une batterie li ion polymère
développée par an broc et il vous faudra
à peu près deux heures et demie pour
venir le recharger à 100% wallon bourse
produits
alors je sais que c'est un peu moins
tels que le reste mais c'est néanmoins
très pratique à une fois de plus ça
vient en complément d'autres aspirateur
robot rock que vous ai déjà présenté
donc ça pour avoir une maison propre
très facilement et pas s'embêter c'est
vachement bien vous de me dire ce que
vous en pensez bien évidemment pas aux
commentaires ce que ça pourrait vous
botter ce produit est ce que vous aviez
déjà le hachis ce que je vous avais
présenté l'année dernière
qu'est ce que ce h7 peut vous faire de
l'oeil pourrez vous file tranquillement
vous marquez tout ça bien évidemment on
bat en commentaire et si vous intéresse
demi tous les liens en bas dans la
description et quant à nous on se
retrouve très vite pour continuer à
parler tech et ça c'est une très bonne
nouvelle des bisous d'amour pour les
soins et à très vite temps